اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن ضم مجرو- مشروع الدرعيه للمشاريع
الخمسه الكبرى والمملوكه لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه ليصبح واحدا من
المشاريع الفريدا من نوعها على مستوى
العالم وتضم منطقه الدرعيه السعوديه معالم
ثقافيه وتراثيه وسياحيه والاتجاه من
ابرزها حي الطريف التاريخي والمدرج على
قائمه اليونسكو للتراث العالمي
هنا قلب على مساحه سبعه كم مربع تاسست
عاصمه الدوله السعوديه الدرعيه قبل 300
عاما تقريبا بتصميم نجدي طينيا مزخرف
بمثلثات من الجسل الابيض مشروع تطوير
الدرعيه الذي اعلنمه الامير محمد بن سلمان
للمشاريع الكبرى اليوم يعد اضخم مشروعا
تراثي حضاري تم الاعلان عنه حتى الان وذلك
لحساسيه وصعوبه التعامل مع المباني
القديمه وتجهيز بنيتها التحتيه لتوام
مخرجات المشروع وسيتم تنفيذه تباعا حتى
2020 نبدا الان مشاهدينا من اصول المشروع
الرئيسيه شمالا يقع حي طريف والذي
سيحتضروس سته متحف منها متحف قصر سلوى
ومتحف الخيل والمال والعماره الساحات
المحيطه بالحيط او يمكننا تسميتها مداخل
الحي ستتحول الى سوق مفتوح الانحراف
والبضائع ولزياده الجذب مشاهدينا ستعتمد
واجهه قصر سلوى لتكون شاشه تفاعليه بالصوت
والضوء وذلك لاستخدامها في عرض الافلام
الوثائقيه التاريخيه والاحتفالات المصاحبه
الى الشرق وحيوا البجاري المرتفع عن حي
طريف والذي جرى افتتاحه مؤخرا يمتد على
مساحات صخريه منحدره ليكون مطلا طبيعيا
مثاليا للاستجمام كوفقا مخطط هيئه تطوير
البوابه الدرعيه سيكون متنزها مفتوحه
كالحيت بارك عبر ممشى بطول ثلاثه كيلومتر
هذه المماشي مشاهدينا المضلله تحيط ب 20
معلما ثقافيا يمكن زيارتها عبر مسارات او
مساراتي للدراجات والخيل ايضا والاضافه
الطابعه الحضاري مشاهدينا للمنطقه ستكون
اكبر نقطه جذب للمطاعم العالميه من فئه مش
لانسر في المملكه بالاضافه الى معهد فنون
اقليمي معتمد وفندق
الى اخر اصول المشروع الثلاث وهو وادي
حنيفه المجرى المائي الوحيد في العاصمه
الرياض وهو احد اكبر وصارف الامطار
والسيول في البلاد يبلغ طوله 120 كيلو متر
خصصت فيه
متنزهات مفتوحه صديقه للبيئه وبها مشاكل
ومطاعم ومراكز تخدمهم هذا الغرض لتسهيل
وصول الزوار مشاهدينا خصصات الهيئه وخاصه
الهيئه ساحه انتظار تستوعب نحو احد عشر
سيارات واخططت لانشاء ثلاثي محطات رئيسيه
لمتر الرياض احداها مرتبطه بالمطاي مباشره
اما حجم المردود الاستثماري للمشروع
مشاهدينا فيقدر بخمسه ريال وصولا لعام
2020 والى المردوده الاجتماعيه لاهل
المنطقه فسوفر المشروع خمسه و50,000
وظيفه جديده